what if health care was as intuitive as
the apps on your smartphone always
improving and getting smarter
what if artificial intelligence guided
your health protocol as efficiently as
GPS guides your car our health care
system is antiquated often broken and
about to be massively disrupted the
future of health care offers a radical
new landscape leading to longer life
better health and lower costs this is a
world where patients will have secured
instant access to their data and where
doctors can access the relevant health
records of patients in real-time
it's a world where artificial
intelligence can pull this data and
offer actionable insights and human
language you can understand and where
these transactions are safe and private
the future of health care will be
patient-centered intelligent and
data-driven so let's unpack this a
little bit today's system is a world
where siloed patient medical records
result in many life-threatening
situations where doctors treating
someone in New York for example can
access their records in Boston often
leading to fatal results so patient data
needs to get where it is needed when it
is needed and in a form that is
practically usable the necessary
paradigm shifts are coming more so than
just patient centered this revolution
will lead to a person-centered system or
interactions with service providers of
all kinds such as doctors specialists
clinics labs hospitals health coaches
pharmacists case managers dietitians
Public Health social services education
services and judicial systems all
revolve around the patient person in his
AI agent and artificial intelligence
that
to all relevant parts collect the data
from all personal health resources and
make sense and contextualize the
person's health all of this points to a
rise of data empowered AI imagine
virtual health assistance and virtual
healthcare experts that manage all the
complexities of your healthcare and
serve up the relevant necessary and
actionable information fluidly and
frictionless and this is only the
beginning a via node is a very
sophisticated software entity that sits
between you the via node owner and every
other node on the internet it is your
agent proxy into the digital healthcare
universe these via nodes can connect to
other via nodes to form identity
verified trust networks each capable of
supporting one or more private
permission to blockchain channels they
can manage the collection exchange and
storage of sensitive health data they
can encrypt health records and manage
which via nodes can decrypt them that
can support interfaces that can talk
human AI based BOTS and avatars talk
Medical FH by our standard
apps open API and talk blockchain and
they can host data enabled apps and
empower your AI resources all of the
above of course in accordance with the
vnode owners rules policies and
procedures using the above capabilities
via nodes can be used to build trust
networks and processes to achieve
patient health data centrality for both
persons and populations which will in
turn empower AI entities and apps to
meet the health needs of patient persons
all of these tools and underlying
features are simply creating the
backbone of a world where biology will
go digital
a world where apps for biology will see
endless upgrades and innovations a
health sector transformed by artificial
intelligence biotechnology and genetics
what begins with Health Care 2.0 will
end with humanity 2.0 the time to
embrace this change is now
[Music]